so hello everybody i would like to
introduce you to dr paula boddington
um dr boddington is a moral philosopher
she teaches at several schools and she's
also
a published author on questions of
morality
uh and several issues as well she she's
kind of dabbles in all kinds of subjects
uh you know i've seen her on television
in the uk she discusses the problems of
ai which is
why i have her on our show today to talk
about
the narratives around ai the ethics of
ai because i know it's something that
interests you
the people that watches this channel
quite a bit
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
so dr paula maybe you can start by
introducing yourself because i
i do what i can uh to introduce yourself
and tell us a little bit
how you got interested in how you you
moved into the field of ai and morality
okay hi uh thanks very much so uh
well i started working on um issues
about ai and ethics about five or six
years ago
just by one of those chances because i
was working with some i was working at
one of the colleges in oxford
and there were a couple of people people
there who were really interested in this
so
we applied and around about the time
what was happening was it was around
about 2014
2015 there was a lot of attention to the
problems of
there might be forthcoming disasters in
relation to ai
so people like stephen hawking and elon
musk were speaking out
um claiming that they're well really
worried
about concerns about what might happen
when we develop ai in the future
and then uh what happened was that
there's an organization called the
future of life institute which is based
in boston
and elon musk donated a whole lot of
money for research projects looking at
beneficial ai
so three of us we put in a proposal and
we're lucky enough to get
we got got one of our grants so i was
working on that for a couple of years
but the topic we were looking at was
developing
developing codes of ethics for ai so i i
worked on that which is
it kind of it's really interesting
there's now there are there are so many
codes of different codes of ethics for
ai all over the world
there's actually a website that collates
and tracks them all but but what i was
really interested in was not so much
developing a code of ethics because
well what i'm really interested in is
looking at the
issues behind that looking at how you
might even start to think about what the
ethical issues are
and then talking about codes of ethics
there's two layers to it because you
don't have just to think about what the
ethical issues are you have to think
about
how you're actually going to bring this
about in practice how you're actually
going to bring about good practice
because
there are so many examples of
organizations that have got fantastic
codes of ethics
and it makes no difference whatsoever
one of my favorite examples is enron
who everyone that you know younger
people might not remember collapsed
disastrously taking the livelihoods of
hundreds of thousands of people had a
fantastic code of ethics there's also a
really fantastic code of medical ethics
um but giving um dignity to the patient
and informed consent that was around in
germany before the second world war
so that was before the nazis so that's
always really really um
really uh important to remember that
kind of thing so so that's how i got to
work into
in the ethics of ai but prior to that
i'd done quite a lot of
other work in philosophy in relation
with uh
i've previously looked looked at work
with teams of genomic scientists looking
at ethical issues and genomics research
and performative clinical genetics and
uh
before that i've done a lot of work in
relation to how we think about what a
person is
so i've done some work in relation to
with a psychologist in relation to how
people with learning disabilities are
are regarded
and i also do so what i've also been
doing because i've done lots of
different bits of work
so this is a really long introduction so
one of the things i've been doing as
well
for the last few years at the same time
as doing work in relation to the ethics
of ai
it's i've been working with the team of
sociologists who do ethnographic work
looking at the care of people with
dementia in hospital boards which is
like
it's really it's such good luck to be
looking doing working those two
different things at the same time
because
they seem like they're worlds apart but
it's really really valuable because
because of it because of a contrast
because of how uh people with
people with dementia are so marginalized
and
and also it's related of course to two
ideas of a loss of cognitive capacity
or on the other hand you've got people
working in ai who feel that intelligence
and cognitive capacity is is
the you know the pinnacle of human
endeavor but we should try to surpass so
sorry it's a really really long
introduction but no but i i think that
it's very
i think that you really right away in
your introduction i kind of
see the the issue or the question
because one of the
the problems that or not of the problem
one of the realities of ai
is that there's a personification of ai
it just happens
naturally you know in terms of how we
how we treat it how we
approach it you know and it's a long
story with robots and
isaac asimov and you know it's a very
old story
it's not something that just right away
happens but we have this tendency to
personify ai and like you said
there is a tendency to de-personify
people who
have cognitive breakdown because we have
associated
personhood with uh with cognitive
ability or with
with mental ability yeah yeah precisely
so
but yeah those are the issues i'm really
really interested in and and when we
think about ai
there are different kind of narratives
that we that are told
not always consistent with each other
but different narratives in different
areas of ai
about ai but they always go along with
an assumed or explicit or often implicit
narrative about humans
because humans and ai are seen in in
relation to each other so that
so but we use ai or the ai is being
developed in order
to sometimes replace humans so when
you'd have to ask the question of why
would you want to replace a human
sometimes for good reasons actually so
so for example um i mean one really good
reason would be if you wanted to clear a
landmark
field of landmines so much better to use
a robot
but so some of it some of it is some of
it's good but so you either want to
replace humans or
you want to try to enhance humans but if
you want to enhance humans if you want
to enhance something
you have to have an idea about what
would make it better
so so you have to have a night because
not all you know
not all changes are enhancements are
they so you have to have some idea about
what it is that humans are lacking so it
always goes along with some idea about
how humans stand in relation to the rest
of the world
and some idea about what faults humans
might have
or what imperfections they might have
that we can surpass and but
it does it does really really tend to to
reinforce there's been work
in moral philosophy for quite a long
time about notions of personhood which i
think are
my personal views they are too biased
towards the cognitive
um but the work in ai only just
reinforces that
well there's something there's something
about what you're saying in the idea of
this image of the golem or right this
image of the artificial being
that we saw you know kind of popped up
very strongly in the time of the the
romantics and you know frankenstein and
all of
this kind of uh narrative um
is very important to understand this
mirror it really does end up acting like
a mirror
yeah and so we end up projecting our
politics
our morality and like you said the the
most dangerous
part of it is that it's often implicit
we don't
actually know so like you said like when
when elon musk says he wants to make
human beings better by
implanting a chip in their brain no one
ever asks
what you're talking about like what is
this better and it usually just means
more powerful
in terms of like adding capacity like it
seems that seems to be
the the the what we're talking about but
adding capacity
you know what is it the spider-man
famous spider-man quote right with great
power
and so adding capacity is not always
something you want to do yes
yes yeah yes it's it's interesting so
one of the things that one of the things
i was just looking up this week
um thinking about talking to you is that
very often you talk about a if you
google it you'll find
lots of people talking about ai
defroning humans
but it's really really quite interesting
as to the context in which that's used
the idea that we've been knocked off our
throne
and actually it's also really
interesting because a lot of people are
kind of like
welcoming that because a lot of people
are really against so a lot of people
say for example have a really simplistic
notion
of a religious view of humanity but
where the crown of creation and
and uh um but no darwin has come along
and not just about petals and that's a
really good thing because we shouldn't
lord it over the rest of verifiable but
if you look at the context in which they
talk about dethroning
ai is defroning humans it it seems a lot
it's often in context of something like
um when alphago beat lee zidol the world
go champion
or at something like chess or something
where there's some where there's some
beating the humans at some intellectual
task or often where it's really really
easy to work out
it's it's if it's really easy to work
out whether somebody's better at go
because they're a criteria for whether
you've won or not completely certain
but but also it's made me think about
the sorts of things that we're worried
about being dethroned because
as far as i know arnold schwarzenegger
is not crying his eyes out
because a forklift truck can lift
heavier things
than he can and and uh you know usain
bolt isn't worried that cheetahs can run
faster than him
so it's it's something it's really is
something about it really does tell a
lot
about why we think that like being
clever at certain things
are kind of defroning us we're not not
at all worried that chimpanzees could a
chimpanzee could rip you from
limb to limb because they're so much
stronger than us we don't care
it's but we don't
some people seem to care about that joe
rogan seems to care about that a lot he
talks about all the time
all right but yeah but yeah
yeah the idea i think that the idea that
you're talking about is
is because we the west has really taken
up the underdog
story as being the story right we've
taken up the revolutionary story as
being
the the story itself and so all our
movies all our stories
you know since the enlightenment have
been revolutionary yes and so because of
that
then there's this surprising thing like
you said
which appears in stories which appears
in something like
the desire to have ai dethroned us or
the desire for extraterrestrials to come
and show us up
or or just even the cuckolding narrative
which has become strangely popular all
of this is
this strange manifestation of this
revolutionary
tendency which turns against you it's
almost like it's like you're
revolutionary but then you
you expect almost almost like implicitly
that something from underneath
is going to come and and take your place
you know and you see that in it's it's
an old story it's the story of the greek
gods how they castrated their father and
then
you know that's what it is it's a it's a
so
one of the things that i've been that
i've been saying on my channel and i've
said it kind of here and there but i
want to say clearly here i guess
because i have some friends that are in
computer science and very smart people
you know who i'm talking about here
the people who are watching this and
they tell me that it's technically
impossible right general intelligence in
computers
is technically impossible and and
it's funny because i don't have no way
of knowing that because i'm not a
computer scientist
what i do know is that it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter
whether it's technically possible or not
it what truly matters
mostly matters is what story we tell
if everybody believes that this is
happening
then that will have way more an effect
way more of an effect than if
it actually happens and you can't know
something's conscious anyways
how can you know that like i can't know
that of you i can't know that of
completely no like i can't know it
internally the way i know
my own consciousness yeah i don't know
how you would even evaluate that no
i always wondered that about about
people talking about ai becoming
conscious because you you know
you don't know if another person is
conscious i remember when i was a
philosophy undergraduate and we had to
write an essay about the problem of
other minds and i spent i spent a whole
week really really really worried
because when you think about it
you don't know that anybody else is
conscious so it's actually that's one of
the things that's really interesting
about how we project
these things onto ai because a lot of
people are talking about oh if if ai or
robots become conscious
then they they've got rights we should
treat them in the same ways we should
treat humans
but it's really interesting because even
if they were conscious you wouldn't you
wouldn't how would you tell they were
conscious
but also how would you know what their
consciousness was like because we look
lots of i mean loads and loads of
animals we assume are conscious but we
don't think they have the same
rights as human beings we don't think
that the dog's got the right to vote
because he's conscious
so it's it's really interesting how
quick how quickly we assume
but um how quickly so many people assume
but also it's i mean actually it's
really human tendency it's a really
human tendency to extrapolate humanity
onto onto things like you see faces of
things all the time
and there's a tendency to sort of
extrapolate humanity onto robots really
quickly or worry
about uh i remember joanna bryerson
who's uh um works in robotics and she
also works now a lot in
ethics she she said she noticed that
when she was working with robots
people would really worry about whether
it was like cruel to unplug the robot
so yeah it's really interesting to
project project onto it but also i think
i think there's another reason for
so we could sorry it's really
it's super it's not it's not just a
little interesting it's
very interesting because what's mostly
interesting about
that to me is the notion of the the
making of a body
right and so the idea that yeah the idea
that you can make a body to host
intelligence is something which has
existed forever that's what idols are
idols have always been you know statues
of gods have always been
the creation of bodies that would host
intelligences and that intelligence
would manifest itself
through proxy like in a proxy through
proxy through it's the believer
that they are the people sacrificing to
that god through this
through this image and so it seems to me
that we're
noted we're seeing something similar
happen now is that
the the let's say the intelligence of
artificial intelligence
is through us like we are the proxies of
the artificial intelligence
it needs us in order to be intelligent
but that doesn't mean that it it
doesn't act the way that an ancient god
would also
act because we trust it like yeah the
way that the ancients trusted the gods
we trust google we trust facebook we
trust these algorithms
we kind of good give our trust and we
all look to it so it ends up acting like
uh
really does end up lacking almost like a
like a god like a ancient god
yes but also also it's worse than that
because we've we've painted ourselves
into a corner
because we have to we have to trust it
because everything is set up
everything is set up in order to have
you have to use it
and even if you aren't you're walking
down the street and it's being used so
we've paid we've painted ourselves into
a corner there
so yeah so say you because there's also
a lot of distrust as
as as well but but it actually gets back
to the question about you say your
computer scientists say you'll never
have
artificial general intelligence which is
i
who knows because others others argue
that you can but
you can it's always in a sense you
always have to oversimplify to explain
points but you can divide
you can divide concerns in ethics of ai
broadly into people who are
looking at the future so the possibility
of super intelligence
um something which might be in the
future sometimes maybe 25 years in the
future or whenever
there's lots of debates about how long
it's going to be if that happens so some
people are worried about
super intelligence and then worried
about whether so that's in two branches
so some people
really look forward to that and think
that is really great and our descendants
will actually be
digital all humans will become digital
so that's one one lot actually think
that
and another lot are really worried about
this and we need to prepare
so one argument is that maybe it won't
happen but we need to be ready just in
case it does
trying to make ai sort of beneficial for
humans and really worried about ai is
going to take control
so there's a worry that in the future
it'll take control and then there are
people who are concerned about what's
happening now with the ai we have now
and all the other computing which is
maybe not quite ai
but i think that's a false dichotomy
because it's already taken control
yeah it's already taken control yeah and
i think the to me the best way to see it
is still in the analogy of the ancient
god or the ancient
temple is that it's taken control
through
through a priestly cast which is what
would have happened in the
all the temples before that the will of
the god manifest
itself through the priestly cast which
in
which informed the people yes you know
and tell them to look to the god right
the people
the cast is saying look to the statue
and then then they are
explaining the will and it's like i'm
i'm not even saying that as if it's bad
like
it's actually how reality works but it's
a fr but you need to know who your
priestly cast is and i think that that's
one of the things that at least
in certain spheres is worrying people
the most is that
these tech elites are not definitely not
uh uh a superior cast like they're
definitely not the people you want to
entrust your civilization to
no no no so yeah i think it's really
important to remember that because when
people talk about
ai being in charge we also have to
remember that but there's there's people
it's actually people doing it
big corporations and and they're half in
charge and half not in charge
that's the problem they don't really
don't really know what they're doing
it's like you've got a pre a priestly
chart cast of heart
half wits really it's like
that's also why that's why so why
there's a it seems like there are some
mechanisms which are
set at hand and so like one of the
things you said at the outset which
really intrigued me
um is the idea that the problem of the
ethics
of like the problem of the ethics of ai
isn't just about deciding what the code
of ai
is it's that there are certain there are
certain patterns which are there
which will lay themselves out and so you
can say whatever you want it's
it's almost as if you said like i'm
going to create an ethics of weapon
making
and my ethics of weapon making is that
you can't use these weapons to kill
people
okay dude it's like that's really nice
but though you're making weapons
right and so and so it's the same with
ai it's like there's a there's an
internal
mechanism to what ai is doing that means
that
you can't just impose an ethical system
on it
you can recognize the ethical
possibilities of it
and you have to and you can try to
implement them as best you can but there
are certain things for example the
the near infinite amount of power that
it can give
certain aspects of reality it's
something that it doesn't matter what
ethical system you apply to
right whatever whatever ethical system
you try to apply to something
which has massive power is not going to
not gonna hold yeah well yes i mean
there's there's so many different things
you could say about that so what so one
of the things that's happening so for
example
it we're trying to sorry i'm stuffing
because there's so many different things
to think about but
there are ways in which people are
trying to make certain that the ethical
systems are as ethical as but
sorry the ai systems are as efficient as
possible so there are loads and loads of
people working on like technical aspects
of
how do we ensure privacy so there's big
big issues with privacy because of all
the data that's been collected all the
time
but not for data that's being collected
for ways in which we can analyze it
so you can extract stuff out of the data
that you had no idea that you could
extract
for example so they could work out but
they can they can work out from um
they can work out from your shopping
habits whether or not you might be
developing dementia
they can work out your mood from how
you're typing they can work out all
sorts of all sorts of things about you
they can guess all sorts of things about
you
but by analyzing the data but um
but so the the way in which we think
about privacy
is all being shaped by how we use the
tech at the same time as we're trying to
make certain that the tech guards are
privacy is that the kind of thing you're
thinking of
so the ways in which the technology
lures us into posting stuff on social
media
the way in which it manipulates our
emotions so that it
it it tends to like twitter for example
tends to incite
the worst emotions it tends to get at
your kind of like angry feeling
so that you you you'll you
then reveal things about yourself that
you wouldn't ordinarily reveal
so so is it so the way in which we're
thinking about
the notion of the self how we relate to
other people how we think
about all those things is changing all
at the same time as we're trying to try
to
call it is that right that's the right
that's exactly the right way to say it
is that it's actually modifying the
manner in which we engage with each
other
yes through in its image yes like in the
image of the tech and so it's having a
like a parasitic effect and i mean
that's also obviously the danger of any
kind of
extern any kind of supplement right is
that it has a parasitic possibility
which is that it then starts to shape
reality to its own image and i think
that
one of the things we saw with like kovid
you know i did this interview with
christian
about marcia mcluhan and he talks about
how
mcluhan said that we're basically
already the sex organs of the machine
and it's like it sounds like something
witty to say and you know you think okay
that's really pithy but uh i think that
i've been seeing it more and more
now with kovid like just how much that's
true because
all of the things that we did for kovid
would not have been possible
without this would not have been
possible without
zoom without social media without all
the technical
technical tools that we have and it
actually modified
our the way that we perceive kovid
because if covet like i'm i'm sorry to
say this for people who have it and and
like have suffered from it but if co if
the
the something the size of kobe had
happened 100 years ago
it would have gone pretty much unnoticed
like it would have not had been it would
not have changed the very structure of
reality like it would have been noticed
like as a disease but it
wouldn't have changed everything yeah
yes so i i'm not we i think we i think
it's a strong argument to be made for
saying we couldn't possibly have had a
lockdown
we couldn't possibly have done a
lockdown if we didn't have the internet
and even even if it was just like 10
years ago or five years ago
then we couldn't possibly have had this
kind of lockdown could we
no it's now this is it's like this is
coveted is the image of
of now and it's the and it's and it
looks like
the internet and let's say this this
technology
yes yes wanting to get th it lives
through attention
and so it's it's actually it's actually
increasing the amount of attention
we give it through through the
mechanisms
its very own mechanisms and how it's
able to
adapt to reality it's like it's like
almost like a weird darwinian thing
where it's like adapting to reality and
taking
opportunities to increase its its its
effect and power yeah yes but it's but
it is
i that the idea that the where the sex
organs of the technology is is kind of
really really intriguing but i also kind
of want to fight back about it a bit
because
if we take that too literally any kind
of it lets the tech guys off the hook
because they are deliberately they are
it does we don't want to let them off
the hook we really don't want it because
otherwise they're just
mark zuckerberg it's just for helpless
pawn and could do nothing so there's a
sense in which they are
there's a combination but it's like
they're they're the doctor evil's
henchmen or something but they're
actually working
in in conjunction with it but yeah so
for william but
i think it's really interesting to have
a way in which we relate to each other
through all this uh
zoom and not and distance meetings is
changing so much of course one thing to
remember is that but lockdown
hasn't changed the lives some people's
lives haven't been changed very much at
all so for people who are delivering
they're still going out delivering
so but it's like it's that's interesting
as well the way in which it helps to
divide people because
it's basically as you could point out
there was a tweet the other day that i
really laughed at
but because you know how tweets are
always taken too literally these days
somebody said
in reality there has been no lockdown
middle class people have been hiding
while working class b people bring them
stuff so there's
wishes and of course there are people
saying oh no no i'm middle class i'm a
doctor i go out
but the point the point is that it's
actually also it does actually divide
people a lot
so the technology divides dude we have
different experience of it
but the way in which we relate to each
other say over zoom
is really really interesting because it
changes how we think of ourselves
because it makes you much more conscious
because you can see yourself so you're
thinking that's right i look stupid do i
look stupid you know
what's in the background like i need to
go to class a couple of months ago and
realized that i had
my washing in the background so i didn't
like didn't want the students to see my
washing
it's all that sort of thing but how we
relate to the other person so
even the visual information you get from
a camera even a really good camera
it's a tiny fraction of what you'd get
if you're in the room with a person
yeah exactly because you don't realize
that when you're with someone
you noticed very small things like
you notice them almost kind of
implicitly the way they're sitting the
way their hand hand is twitching the way
you know the smell of the room the
there's so much
happening like you know you notice how
you notice like how
dirty someone's hair is or like it's
like these little things that you
sense when you're with someone and it
gives you an impression of how that
person's doing or
you know what's kind of going on around
them whereas with zoom
you know and and it's just it's a it's
another version of something like social
media you know i've argued
for a while that social media is is
basically
you know a form of of showing yourself
and
and then watching other people it's like
entertainment brought to the individual
level
and it's not true it's not true
interaction right it's a form of
even this like obviously we're having a
public discussion right this is not
the same discussion we would have if we
were sitting together in a in a
you know in a coffee shop no no it had
been a cup of tea for a start and yeah
exactly
yeah it would be but there was something
i've been thinking about recently which
is which
i'm really would be interested to know
what the effect of this is because also
again like in lockdown i think the
experience of there are millions of
people who've been in lockdown
completely on their own
for months after month after month so i
think that experiences could well be
really quite different but then one of
the things i was thinking about in terms
of
in terms of i was thinking about it in
terms of how ai
um ai sort of runs on electricity and
the importance of electricity and then
it occurred to me
but of course we run on electricity as
well as biological creatures
and our electric fields from our bodies
extend beyond our bodies
so but i actually have no idea what
impact that would be and whether you
could pick it up from other people if
you're in the same room as people
i'm just thinking about the physical
distance of not phys
because we can communicate as much as we
want sort of
verbally yeah no but i think i think
you're absolutely right you know the
idea that you know that someone's
looking at you from behind
is real like that's not fake when you
know all of a sudden you know someone's
looking at you
yeah and it's like but that why would
that like i don't know why that would
bother anybody
like why would that bother you because
animals have all kinds of yeah
of of ways of perceiving that are not
just like the four senses or whatever
so i think that you're right that we
obviously that this technology is
is extremely focusing like it's
extremely limiting in terms of our human
experience
with my kids i see it it's nuts like my
kids you know
we had very limited tech in our house so
very very limited like
an hour of of watching something a week
pretty much
uh and then kobe did and we just
lost absolutely there was no way because
the only way they could have
contact with their friends was through
was through uh digital
and then you realize that some of your
kids
actually prefer it because it's safe
yes yeah right it's it's safe because
you have total control over what you're
projecting yes and you you don't you
don't have all the side effects of
of a conversation you know and all the
possibilities of
of misspeaking and of of of making a
mistake and you know of whatever of
having a
snot come out your nose or whatever it
is that kind of disc
little thing that can happen that makes
you embarrassed or makes you whatever
in a real conversation it's much it's
nice and clean
yes but but it does focus towards
certain parts of the experience wasn't
it
because i think all of this tech focuses
very much on cognitive and linguistic
and in a way and away from embodiment i
mean i was thinking about
i was thinking about it like being so
distant from people so it just occurred
to me that like the family i'm from like
my mum and dad
especially my dad really we're not the
sort of family who actually spoke very
much
you know we weren't terribly chatty you
know what i mean but you still want to
go and see somebody and you would like
i'd often spend
hours with my dad just like sitting
together in silence
but and it's that kind of thing it made
me if that's thinking about that maybe
you really realize how this is all
focusing towards certain aspects of
human experience only
so would that be an example of how the
technology itself is
is is twisting stuff without it even
actually having any content the way in
which it's
the way in which it's where using it is
yeah and there's also a kind of it's
also it's all based on attention
which is really important i mean i i
kind of talk about that
a lot how attention is the basis of
reality
but the the tech companies and these
these platforms they seem to have
understood that and now they are using
it in
a crazy manner because the like like the
likey thing
is so smart like whoever came up with
the like button
is an absolute demonic genius like it's
a
it's amazing because you can get pure
attention yes yes it does it's not messy
or it's not messy attention it's not
like the kind of attention
where someone is looking at you and and
all of a sudden you see something in
their eyes and you don't understand what
it is like are they angry with you or
like it's none of that it's just like
like yeah pure
pure attention yes like like or dis like
or dislike
yeah exactly it doesn't matter really
it's all about quantity of attention
yes yes yes it is but it's only a it's
it's not attention the same as a sort of
attention if you really wanted to attend
to a person
but that is going to be that's really
complex attending to a person is really
really complex
thing to do isn't it if you're really
but it's it's
so it's it's sort of attention but it's
only attention to a tiny bit of
attention it's a currency of attention
attention transformed into currency
because that's what it is
and it's hilarious because you know it's
like i fall in that all the time people
ask you
how many people are following you on
youtube how many people are following
you on twitter and you tell them
right and then you see in their eyes
that it gives you power
it's like i have so much attention this
is how
this is the the currency of attention
that i hold and like
if i want to be invited on a podcast or
if i want to to have up someone comment
my on my
on my show my currency of attention is
going to
decide whether or not they'll accept and
so it's like
it's a very i mean it was always kind of
like that obviously prestige has always
been a part of
of how how things work but now it's been
so quantified and it's
it really is a type of currency yeah
yeah it's yeah it's interesting it's
really interesting how it's quantified
so you can like count
you can count but i mean that's just you
can count the likes yeah you can see
there's a number and it's like
you can see how many people have said
they like you
yes it's not about quality it's just
about quantity because
you know it's like someone the one
person saying they like something
because they're scrolling through and
they see it and they find it mildly
interesting and
they just like it and another person who
sees it and it like changes their life
and then all they can do is still just
click like like yeah you know
or low or put a heart instead of a
thumbs right it's like
just a little a little more but still it
just shows you
how much it has been transformed into uh
and just a kind of quantifiable currency
yeah yes so what i was gonna say like
that for example like that system let's
say that this system
now if you try to apply an ethical
layer on top of that right
it's limited by the very system itself
but the very system
of let's say current turning attention
into currency
will reduce the ethical possibilities of
that system i don't know if that makes
sense
yeah i think so but i was just going to
point out something
something really paradoxical at this
about how this is if this relates to ai
and computing
so the value of ai we can see the
currency of that
is intelligence and trying to introduce
cognitive capacity and intelligence is
in fact the most important part
of human beings but then how it treats
us
is nothing to do with intelligence it's
it's it's hitting the sort of basic part
of ourselves
it's like hitting raw emotion and not
just even general emotion but just a
really
just just a really attenuated part of it
so so for ways in which
yeah so this is an aspect of control
that's like really really disturbing i
think and really really worrying
and and also a big split in how on what
values there are in the system so
that it's you especially see this in a
lot of a futuristic
futuristic talk about ai it's as if
there's a lot of a futuristic talk as if
uh humans are okay we're pretty
intelligent we've come as far as we can
get
and then the next stage is going to
produce even more intelligence to try to
either have a transhumanist to extend
our intelligence or maybe just see
um but that biology is has got its
limits and we need to go into a digital
form and get more and more and more
intelligence
so there's that aspect of it but then
how we're being treated
is we're being we're basically being
treated like farm animals
right we're just basically being treated
like like objects
yeah yes when you've reduced
intelligence to quantity
then and i mean the mecha and you
mechanize it and you you have this idea
that mechanized reality is
somehow higher then then you're treated
like a machine that's just how it's
gonna it's not
you can't stop that right it's yes yeah
yes yes yes so we just we just
manipulated some emotions our emotions
are just manipulated
and yeah and just just reducing us then
yeah
and so like for example like if you but
this is also one of the ways that for
the idea of like submitting to a god
let's say and how
once you do that then you can't change
let's say the the direction right
so i have this contention maybe i'm
wrong maybe i give them too much good
good uh good reasons for their action
like good intentions but
you know what i think that like when
facebook and twitter started
they basically they understood one
insight which is attention
we just need to keep people's attention
yeah and then they didn't at
all realize that the easiest way to get
someone's attention
right is through appealing to the lizard
brain right appealing to the rawest
emotion you can appeal to and then then
you'll get have their attention
and so now they're it's like they they
were
they set up a like an ideal like they
set up this false god and now they're
paying the price for it and they don't
know what to do with the
with the results of it and it's like so
how what do you do now that you've
created this
well i i suppose there's quite a lot you
could do
there's but yeah there's a sense in
which they they've created something
they don't know what to do with
but also there's another sense in which
if you're already if you're a
billionaire you've got quite a lot of
choice
about what you do and it's
and there's there's a lot there's a lot
going on which is like really shocking
and awful of the things that they
but the the way in which you're
projecting is it so here's an example
a lot of the stuff it's it's as if
they're projecting this idea
so one of the narratives is there's an
idea that ai is going to take over it's
going to do
a lot of work for it make life better
for for humanity in general
and that's a beneficial ai movement is
all about that
but if you look at a lot of the things
that's happening with things like social
media and facebook
there's an underclass there's all sorts
of work all sorts of hidden work that's
going out
to human beings actually doing it so
appalling jobs doing content moderation
which are generally really really poorly
paid and a job that no human being
should have to do having to look at the
relationship
it's just just horrendous and a lot of
the stuff a lot of
stuff like in machine learning is farmed
out to people people who are
labeling images and doing sort of it's
actually people doing the labor
so in a sense it's a bit of a it's a bit
of a con disabled it's a machine's doing
it because there's armies and armies of
people doing it
really low grade really really poorly
paid people so that's a really
interesting point because it it like you
said because
intelligence actually comes from humans
like real intelligence
yes so what they're doing is they're
farming intelligence
in people yeah they're feeding it to the
machine
yes yeah yeah right yeah yeah yeah
that's what it is
that's really fascinating it's like like
and it's interesting that it's like you
said it it inevitably happens that the
people that are doing this like the
content moderation
and the image labeling are like semi
slaves right there they're at the bottom
of the social
sphere yeah they get paid minimum wage
or whatever
yeah you know and and uh they work at
night and do all kinds of craz like it
they end up looking like the dregs of
society
you know and so then it it even it even
makes even more sense to imagine it like
like the matrix like really the matrix
but instead of like instead of
getting body instead of farming for body
which is what the matrix
uh suggests right is that they they're
getting energy from the human they're
not
it's the opposite they're actually
farming intelligence and
farming farming uh capacity to
the capacity to identify quality because
that's what
the machine doesn't have so yeah you get
that from the humans
yes yeah yes but yes but yeah it's
really interesting
yeah sorry for somebody it's really
interesting so another dirty secret is
it uses up masses of energy
so it's like it's really really energy
hungry so a lot of us a lot of the stuff
is
a lot of stuff a lot of stuff is really
really hidden and it's it's
it's not at all what you expect so you
but so that's a dive
that's a real divergence in the
narratives there's a narrative for in
the future
but we'll have lives of endless leisure
and be able to do whatever we want to be
really creative and so on because the ai
is doing
all the stuff which is uh really
interesting as if the work is going to
be
really fascinating but yeah that's
yeah that's that's that's wonderful yeah
that's very
that is very that it definitely does
show you
i mean i think the content moderation is
one of the most fascinating
i sense is that it's almost like the
people who do
content moderation have to be lured in
like you said from very low uh like
low lungs of society because who in
their right mind yeah
would do that like everybody knows that
doing that would destroy you
yeah it's like you hear those ads on tv
like you hear those ads on the radio
of like going to test pharmaceutical
products like the people who do that
are the same people who will be doing
content moderation because
yes yes yes yes yes yeah
yeah it's really terrible but but as you
say it's for humans have to make the
judgment
i mean that would be given that you're
gonna have to have people doing content
moderation that would be one thing that
you really would want
to be able to train an ai to do because
you really do not want any human being
to ever
have to do that and it i mean some of
the stuff would have to then be handed
over
over to the police wouldn't it some of
the stuff some of the stuff there is
like illegal and needs to be
given to the police like yeah i'm sure
it happens all the time yeah yeah
but um but then if the thing is that you
don't want the ai to
be in charge of that because the the
problem is always the side effect of
power
yeah right and so in the sense that it's
like it's it's almost it really you know
what it is
it's like uh the genie and the wish
that's what we're getting yes
you know the genie comes and says you've
got to wish and then the person
wishes but the genie gives that with
absolute power
yes and so the person never thought of
the side effect of what they wish for
and then the side effect comes crashing
in yes yes yes yes
so yes so so we keep on coming back to
the fact that you
you that you really do need humans in
all of this so one of the one of the
side effects one of us like side effects
of what's going on in social media
are things like the proliferation of
so-called hate speech that's like a
really interesting thing to think about
because
there are loads and loads of people
working on say developing algorithms
to be able to detect hate speech so that
you can automatically take it off
but of course you i you i mean you'll be
able to work out a lot of the problems
with that straight away
because detecting irony is a little bit
of a problem for a machine
yeah yeah it's a problem for a lot of
people actually detecting irony
so so there are problems then you get
problems where so there are also people
working on bias in all the data because
he wanted to
eliminate bias and that's that's another
whole story as well so ben is bias in
hate speech because certain language
groups or subcultures will maybe do
something which seems
to hate speech but then there's also a
problem that it's really interesting how
it how it creates itself because
one of the reasons so it all feeds into
then cultural issues
so one of the reasons why you might so
let's suppose we take the idea of hate
speech
one of the reasons why there's so much
stuff which counts as hate speech
is because of how social media works
it encourages it so it's created the
problem and then it's trying to solve a
problem
but it all spills over into society
because as well as this happening
we have issues that going on in culture
where people are now
falling out having rows getting thrown
off social media
um all those kinds of stuff and then the
idea of hate speech is then getting
built into laws various kind of laws so
there's a really interesting
this is one of the reasons why i i think
we need to modify the idea that
whoever sex organs of a machine because
there's far more complex going on as
well
so we can't just look at the technology
we have to look at what's simultaneously
happening
in in the culture and how that feeds
back into it
yeah so what you said about hate speech
is actually brilliant because
like you said the the anonymization
and the fact that we are physically
distanced from someone and we can forego
getting punched in the face right by
saying something offensive
means that people have feel like they
have all the opportunity to
to let loose their id and to let loose
all these
darker aspects of them and then
the same system which brought it about
is now trying to clamp down and
it ends up like you said spilling out
into
into normal society and then it ends up
becoming a
becoming the standard by which we we
have rules
in in reality yes because like when i
meet someone in real
life you know the type of insult that's
uh that you would be capable of
do saying online is you'll be really
reticent to do that in person
i mean some people will but it's very
rare and and that person will be
ostracized quite rather quickly
yeah yeah and then things can happen
like you know pylons on twitter so
you're not going to get that in real
life where somebody else is going to
join in and
like thousands of people who just start
like giving you death threats
that doesn't happen in like when you're
walking down the street and you you know
you
flip off someone or you like say
something you're saying something stupid
yeah yeah but then but then of course
people can get then of course the
solution is it can also be a problem as
well because people get ousted
unfairly so you you so there's no kind
of right answers people can get thrown
off
throw off social media and then
then there's a there's a there could be
you can say oh you don't need social
media but there's a problem we've become
so
we've become so used to it and their
appeal actually was really interesting
last term i was in the middle of writing
a lecture on censorship online
i thought i just checked twitter only to
discover that my twitter account had
been suspended
so i have no idea why not i have no idea
why not you had this real
really weird appeals process i had to
put in an appeal
and say why it was i thought that i
shouldn't have been suspended
but i didn't know why i'd been suspended
so i couldn't reply it's really
it's really it's like it is like and
this is something that i've seen
it's it's really insane it's like it's
almost it's a strange thing it's like
how is it that tech companies are
bringing about
the like kafka state like the the insane
bureaucratic communist type state where
you don't even know who to talk to you
don't know like
there's no human on the other end of the
line you have no idea how to
to appeal to whatever it is they're
doing to you and like you said and
because they're afraid of you gaming
their system then they make all their
rules completely opaque yes
yeah yes yes it's it's yeah it's
it's yeah it's really interesting it's
really interesting that you have no idea
what to do what to do about it
but it's also interesting that but a lot
of people working
i think haven't actually necessarily
thought about the problem of
being the problem of being ousted
because of hate speech because they
assume
because a lot of people working on this
problem there are lots and lots of
people working on this problem
technically and we're looking at hate
speech and how the algorithms work and
so on
but a lot of them have certain
assumptions i've noticed have certain
assumptions where
it hasn't occurred to them that the hate
speech is going to be biased in certain
directions
so it actually was interesting a couple
of months ago i was reading a paper
where some
researchers had looked at an algorithm
but facebook uses
and how it tends to uh be biased towards
what they call hyperactive users so
certain users who are on
online a lot and comment a lot and
so the algorithm boosts them so they get
more visibility in facebook
yeah so you might kind of think well
good for them they're putting in the
effort
but they were concerned about this when
i first read it i said concerned about
it because
these groups tend to be far right but
they want to read it again
i'd actually misread it they were just
concerned that the groups were
right-wing
yeah so it wasn't and they were
concerned that
they have a certain that they're biased
politically it's because they're
concerned that they were right-wing i
think hang on a second you are allowed
to be right-wing
aren't you last time i looked it's
because they have them people writing it
have got themselves
their particular bias yeah they're and
they're blind to it they don't even
see it's like yeah you hear it all the
time it's like it's like oh but he's
right wing i'm like what
wait what is that did you just say that
as if it's like
he's not human or like that he shouldn't
exist because
because he's right-wing that is just and
and people will say it like just
like that without even thinking i know
yeah it's really weird but that's quite
new i think it's quite new so i think
that's
i think that's that's an exam well i
think it's an example i think that's an
example of how the tech of a culture
were kind of
working hand in hand to accelerate that
so another example is another example of
a lot of the stuff that's going on is
really contradictory so on the one hand
a lot of bai a lot of the ai is tending
towards uniformity
so uniformity of language the dominance
of english for dominance of particular
sorts of english actually yeah
the dominance of of american in american
english
um and oh things like um you know that
when we spoke before we were talking
about that annoying i find it really
annoying when you're writing an email
and tries to write for you suggest yeah
gmail does that yeah yeah yeah so that's
gonna that's gonna sort of unify
and but at the same time fragmenting a
different to different identity groups
but you might think those are intention
but
the social media is actually encouraging
and enabling
the identity identity groups to happen
and it happens so quickly
because so for example the different
different gender categorizations
that has happened so fast the
proliferation of gender categories
it could never have happened as fast as
that before the internet it just could
never have happened because we don't
communicate
so quickly it could never have happened
as fast as that yeah and also because
it's
because let's say people with
alternative gender
like identification are so rare
but because they appear as a
marginalized group
on the social media platforms so the
social media platforms want to protect
them because they're marginalized
therefore bolster their voice therefore
make them appear
as yes a substantive like category of
of human of society when
when in reality you know like actual
transgender people are
like how many people like unless you're
in that scene you'll maybe meet one or
two transgender people
you know in in in the world like you
rarely meet
people like that unless you're like
really in a certain scene
so i mean i mean that's just that's fine
that's it's that's reality but it's
it just like you said the very system
itself creates this weird thing
and then because it bolsters let's say
the group then it also ends up
attracting attention to it
and then for attracting people who want
to
bash because that's just just how it
works
yeah yeah yeah yes and it's also it's
also actually
linked to a consequence of trying to do
the right thing ethically
so there's quite rightly concern about
being biased because who wants to be who
wants to be biased who wants to exclude
people but because there's such a
concern about being biased
in the data and biased online that that
feeds into the idea that you need to you
need to protect these minorities
because because of a focus on particular
particular minorities but
um but i also discovered something i
also discovered something really
interesting you know famous
facebook's famous 70 different two
different genders yeah
identities that you could have like i
was looking it up
and you could if you put in your gender
you have to start typing it if you drop
down menus and different
different sorts of different sorts of
ones but then underneath it
is underneath it there's one that you
can click interested in who you're
interested in and when you click on that
the options it's not 72 options the
options are
men or women you're funny
they could have at least added the other
70 back in there you know it's like
have this like exponential possibility
it's like
because then they're like wait a minute
how like we don't really actually
we're like we just want attention so we
don't care what you say you are we just
want to know
what you're attending to it's like if we
put 70 down there then we can't
be a lot harder to track that it'll be
harder to have our algorithms
you know like to sell that data yes yeah
yeah yeah
that's probably why oh mercy that yeah
that is
that is some frightening stuff but so
what ends up happening this is a
fascinating thing is that because
there's so much power
that in order to like for example in
order to counterbalance this
the hate then they create this weird
upside down
world like it's actually there right if
you write straight couple
on google you'll get gay couples
all right right or you'll get straight
couples that are talking about
homosexuality or that say like i think
one of the top things on google that
came if you wrote straight couple was
something like
a straight couple that said we won't get
married until lgbt rights are
are accepted you know right so it's like
so you get this like weird
this like really strange world where
it's like it's like you want like
let's say you you they end up having to
to
promote the margin to a certain extent
like more than
normal right and so it creates this like
i talk about this weird upside down
hierarchy which ends up manifesting
itself
yeah yeah and of course and of course
there's a margin of a margin because
it's only going to be
the really vocal people the only the
only the activists who are going to be
out there
because there must be there must be lots
of transgender people who just want to
carry on and live their lives of course
i would say probably most yeah yeah but
that's why
it's because it's an attention economy
so it's even more like it always used to
be that the squeaky wheel gets the
grease but now
it's it's it's it's increased by the
very system
yes the fact that people can can can
congregate
and become mobs right they become these
attack mobs and they do all these
these these uh these kind of gestures
online
um yeah but so it's fascinating like
i mean and it's fascinating one of the
most fascinating things
is that what ai is doing is that it's
basically
just giving more power like huge amounts
of power
to whatever it is that's leading it like
to whatever
this priesthood has power and so
it seems like the fight like the the
cultural fight and that's something
people haven't
i think there's a little bit of it like
the fight for what comes up on the first
page of google
like that should probably be the
ultimate culture war
like what it is that appears on the
first page of google because that's
really
it's become like the frame of of of
reality
and it's clear that it's not it's there
are people
behind that like you can see like
there's something when you auto type
then it doesn't
auto type it and then something just
doesn't there's all these things and you
know that there's like people pulling
the strings
behind yes yes but yeah but it's like
the wizard of oz it's actually
it's actually it's wonderful because
they can just say it's the algorithm
they can even make ai they can even
point ai and say oh it's these
algorithms it's not it's not
uh it's not our bias right it's not our
bias isn't there it's just these
it's just ai doing it but yes that might
also be one of the more frightening
aspects of ai
yes yeah yeah yes i mean the whole
notion of bias is really interesting as
well actually
because because it tends to rest upon an
idea that we can get an unbiased view of
the world
and my my view of the world is unbiased
what are you talking about
but together to get an unbiased view how
would you get non-biased view of the
world
you want to collect all the data and you
can't
the world is not just collecting data
you'd have to analyze it so how could
you get a completely unbiased view of
analyzing the data so so
that again but about actually so some
interesting things can come up so
when when people talk i mean if you if
you say anything critical it sounds like
you're against
trying to get rid of bias but what i'm
interested in how people speak
about it and failed to see that
underneath it you've got to have some
view of how the world is divided up
so um so it's not yeah it's not it's not
the problem
of saying you want to get rid of bias
it's the problem of saying you want to
get rid of bias but secretly wanting to
impose your bias on everybody else
yeah that's really the problem right
it's not like if we had a normally
like if we had like a normally
recognized hierarchy of
being that it's like we recognize it we
see its problem we see it's and we just
say this is what it is right
let's say like the ancient world is like
okay so you have the king
you have the the bishop or the pre or
the pope
and it's like and then the world kind of
lays itself out so you can hate the king
but he's still above you and you you
recognize that hierarchy
and so and then the world kind of lays
itself out in that way and everybody
kind of knows
that that's how it happens but now
because we say
no there is no hierarchy right it's
equal
and it's objective and it's all this
stuff but then
secretly there is a hierarchy there's
like a secret
hierarchy and a secret bias that no one
wants to acknowledge
this is something that has been
frustrating so many people in the media
as well like not just media like media
and social media companies that
they keep saying that they're being
objective but
obviously they're not we just wish they
would tell us yeah just say that you're
not and so at least we can start
there yes yeah yes yes yeah but there's
i mean it's
one of the really interesting things
about about the emphasis on bias
is because i think it also speaks to an
idea about
the idea about what's what ai like how
ai sees what's wrong with humans
and way in which ai might seem to be
better than humans
so it's like if you if you this is
talking in really really crude
simplistic terms but if you think of ai
as being better than us because of the
intelligence and its data processing
capacity
then it's as if the problems with human
decisions come in
from from our biases and that's because
of our emotions
which and the emotions are getting in
the way of getting to the right answer
and being completely objective so
that's that's really really interesting
because the emotions are seen as
so on the one hand having these emotions
and being biased because of our emotions
it seemed to be
a problem whereas at the same time as
we've seen the whole system
is working on manipulating our emotions
so it's kind of like
it's slapping us around the face like
accusing us of stuff
but then encouraging us to do the same
thing is you do what i mean
yeah and that seems to be like the the
that seems to be kind of what tim cook
was trying to get at in his
speech at the edl uh where he talks
about
the god out of the machine and he says
he's he's saying he actually doesn't
like the idea like he says i don't think
that
ai can do it on its own but he says it's
people behind the ai
and then he says that's the god out of
the machine which is even more
frightening to me
it's actually even scarier to me because
it's like
it's like mr cook is like i really don't
want you as the god
riding on the machine not you seriously
my friend yes
that frightens me tremendously yeah yeah
because yeah
i mean it so quickly goes to a sort of
totalitarianism because that
these guys are not elected you can't get
rid of them yeah
it's it is it's much more frightening
isn't it so the power of the tech
companies
it the power of tech companies in
relation to to politicians and to
politics is
is is is uh it's a really frightening
thing actually
no is well i mean i would say that this
uh this election the american election
was basically run by social media maybe
the last one too
but this one for sure like they they
just decided some things you're not
allowed to talk about
yeah you're not allowed to talk about
certain things and then and then certain
things are
put up at the top you know of trending
and so
that's just it ends up being and also
because we're all on lockdown anyways
and we're all looking at our screens all
day yeah yeah so it's like
it just it just it's it has become
the ultimate totalitarian possibility is
right there in front of us
it's right there in the situation in
which we're in yes yes yeah
yeah yeah quite right so i think it's
one of the reasons why
it's the idea that worrying about super
intelligent ai and the future taking
control of us is just a misnomer because
it's already it's already
happened it's already happening but but
then
on the other hand i really do think that
we have to try not to sort of
cancel despair because we had to try and
do something about
it what do you think we can do what do
you think we can do about it
well i suppose there's stuff happening
already isn't it like people trying to
set up alternative um
you know alternative social media and
yeah like parlor right
yeah yes then it was deleted
yes right and so i don't it's like right
now it feels like
their their the control is
is extremely strong it seems like it's
going to be very difficult to
create alternative narratives and also
because also because the alternative
narratives like i don't know if you saw
the article
on the times in the in the new york
times today
about uh what is the name of this
this new app where you just talk man i
can't believe i can't ever forget what
it is
anyways it's this new i don't i don't
i'm not on it but it's like this app
where you just
pop into conversations so you have these
conversations right you can just
pop into a conversation and they were
saying unfettered discussions are being
had on this app
and they were seeing it as a bad thing
what yes
they were saying unfettered discussions
are being had and it raises the problem
of
intimidation and bullying and all this
stuff and you're like
it's insane and so yeah and so and you
see it like
even the some articles have been going
out against uh
the uh the messenger applications like
the encrypted messenger application
saying
like this is shady shady these these
shady applications that are encrypted
you know why you know we why would you
want to hide your conversations
it's like it's just insane that it's
become
it's become it's been taken for granted
that private conversation
yes is in itself yes shady
yes yeah and that's that's something
that you really have to watch out about
because that
that thought then just can translate
into a real world so for example
in um in scotland at the moment for
example they're discussing there's a new
hate crime bill up for discussion
and one of the aspects of it was to
repeal
there's a private dwelling exception for
um like hate speech
that you could you like basically but
you're but if you're inside you're
getting say things in your house well
there's discussions about whether we
should get rid of that
but i kind of think that what's
happening on social media is
is like warming a brain up for thinking
that maybe that's a good idea
but but of course luckily there's a huge
backlash against it
there's a there's a huge backlash
against it so
um one of the things that's happening in
lockdown is we're forced into all this
social media but i do wonder on
what might happen when if we ever get
out of it i kind of think we might be
like
have you ever seen cows let out at the
end of the winter
you know when they're left under the
fields and they jumper i think we might
be like that
so but i think that we might just kind
of realize what we've been missing
and maybe we'll see a good thing someone
someone
it's hard to know what these polls are
real or not but someone uh
posted a poll in the u.s saying 75
percent
of people say they'll still wear masks
after covid
so yeah yeah we take your mask off
during a zoom call though that's all
good
yeah it's yeah it's it's difficult see
because
is it one of the things i find really
interesting about working in the ethics
of ai i kind of like the most
interesting area i've ever worked in
because partly it's like it's the most
scary but also i think when we're
when we're looking really really closely
at how the technology might clash with
human values
i think it has got the potential to be
really really fruitful and useful
because it helps to remind us of what
we're missing
helps to remind us what our real human
values are so
yeah and if you can use the things
you're saying to put a mirror up to
people so that we can see
ourselves in the way that we talk about
ai and the narratives that are
surrounding our eyes yeah yeah that's
yes that's probably the first step
in helping us yeah yeah major pitfalls
yeah yeah but it's i was yeah
it it maybe we'll maybe there'll be
little groups you know like in um
is it i can't remember it's brave united
in brave new world when they got the
savages
is it was it i get it yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah brave new world they
they have like this little tribe of
savages
we can be a few groups of savages that
actually like
that actually see each other face to
face that might be good yes yeah
but but i also think one of one of one
of the big problems
one one of the background problems for
when people are trying to think about
the ethical issues here ever paucity of
how they're thinking about it
so a lot of a lot of the work that i see
around ai ethics is basically built into
what you might broadly
call like broadly utilitarian or broadly
consequentialist ways of looking at
things
which also fits into the ways in which
intelligence is
is understood so so those are really
interesting narratives i think as well
i've been running behind ai
so there's lots and lots of different
disputed definitions of how you might
define intelligence and lots of
different forms of intelligence
but but but the form that's often used
which fits really well with computing is
the idea that something along the lines
of
the intelligence is the capacity to
reach your goals to be able to take
steps to reach your goals
so that intelligence is just
instrumental but it's like it's just
like a
an instrumental account of like a
means-end rationality that you have a
goal that you're
aiming to aiming towards so then it fits
really neatly
it fits really really naturally into a
utilitarian way of looking at things
where you're going to try to produce as
much benefit as possible we have certain
goals and preferences
so that it fits into notions of trying
to maximize happiness
or minimize unhappiness or looking at
how we might achieve our desires or
achieve our preferences so
it tends to fit into that so one of the
problems with that is that it fits in
it fits into a an idea of reason that
fits really well into say like an
enlightenment ideal of reason that we're
just
making progress because we're having
more and more rationality
or where we're achieving more and more
of our goals
like a stephen pinker type view yeah
yeah yeah and then everything but
the thing is that it's i don't i don't
actually mind that way of seeing
uh intelligence the capacity to reach
your goals
it's just that the there are higher
goals and there are lower goals
yes and so the world like on the
materialist world and this even pinker
world
it's like it's a lower world it's a
world of
of whims and desires and pleasures and
pain
whereas virtue and the good
let's say in a in a christian sense or a
platonic sense
that's the goal right that that's
actually the the actual goal of
reality and not only is it the goal of
reality but it is
also the achilles heel of artificial
intelligence which is why it has to farm
because what it's farming from people is
not it's not just
it's not information it's the good it's
it's farming quality the red the
capacity to recognize
quality and and to engage in quality yes
that's with the purpose
yes and so it's flipping everything
upside down where
it's it's instrumental it's you it's
using instrument to
i can't say that word making
instrumental the
the the capacity to view quality in
order to attain
practical more like money-making
and desire desire filling goals
so yeah but yeah but but i think
that's i agree but i think that's one of
the points where that's one of the
points where it might flip and turn on
its head because people
will realize the futility of it so you
can you can see those kinds of things
in narratives or discussions around how
what we might do if super intelligent
ai develops how we might be protected so
the idea that you might need to um one
of the wonderful worries that if it's
like
it's like the um the wish fulfillment
worry but if you program
a super intelligent ai to say make us
happy
then what it might do is like plug us
into electrodes so that we're just
getting our present
centers stimulation just getting
endorphins yeah
injected into our brain yeah so for
people working so we don't want that
we don't we don't want that we can't
have that so he's like oh sam harris
talks about that
positively all the time yeah yeah my
goodness
yes yeah i know said but actually it's
interesting because these debates have
been going on in philosophy for a long
time
so the utilitarian it's it's it comes
out of the discussions about
utilitarianism people have been talking
about this for a long time because they
discovered
decades ago that that's what rats would
do if you if you put their brains
that's what they do they do it until
they like collapse with exhaustion um
so but of course you you would have to
be out of your mind
to out of your tiny mind to think that
that was a good way of living life
wouldn't you it kind of
you would have to be out your tiny mind
so then you then as a branch was looking
at we need to try to fulfill human
desires
but you also really quickly realize that
fulfilling your desires which desires
so there's a problem about which desires
you choose but it makes it worse
because of what ai is already doing to
us because it makes it absolutely
apparent but how easily our desires can
be manipulated
yeah absolutely yeah but see the worst
part and this is
the worst step is when the people behind
ai
understand the nature of desire and
actually understand
that human beings are religious in
nature
and then they'll try to implement that
[Laughter]
so we bet it's better to have zuckerberg
like moronic zuckerbergs
for now than have someone who actually
understands
let's say the let's say the qualitative
aspect of
the the human person and how it looks
for communion real communion and
towards a transcendent ideal and then
like they you don't want them to get a
grab of that and try to
plug us into that because that's going
to be right
well well on that
we probably should finish our
conversation yeah yeah yes yeah
whatever sorry that i'm more of a
doomsayer i i feel like i've been
constantly pulling the rug from under
your feet here oh well well i mean
but i just yeah you might be my you
might be right
i'm just kind of trying to it's partly
because i don't want the tech guys
to get off the hook but but yeah i think
even if there's a sense in which even if
you're right we have to try not to be
too doomsayery especially because
there's a pandemic on
we don't want to be too gloomy yeah
so what's your final word on this so
i'll let you have the final word on
possibilities for the future or for us
as people to
to to deal with this well i think for us
for people to deal with this i think we
need to realize that actually we still
have free will
we can still we we still have some
control over it
and but we can also use it we can also
use it to good because it's in
opening up um all sorts of transmission
of knowledge and understanding
different sorts of things and
communication and just use it for that
and and and but also really really think
really really deeply about
what kind of life you actually want to
live you know
well yeah dr paula thank you so much for
your time
and i'm really looking forward to seeing
the conversation that's going to be uh
to be had in the in the comment section
and i'm sure we
we'll have another discussion at some
time that yeah that would be great
because there's some fair
i had loads of questions i wanted to ask
you and i haven't asked any of them
all right we'll definitely then we'll
definitely have another conversation
okay yeah yes yes okay great
okay it's good to talk to you you too
okay bye-bye bye-bye
so i hope you enjoyed my discussion with
paula boddington about artificial
intelligence the stories and ethics that
surround it
by now the symbolic world is a whole
network of things there are of course
these videos there's a podcast version
of these videos that goes out
there's also a clips channel run by
several people um that are moderators
and on the facebook group as well
and we also have a blog where a lot of
symbolic thinkers are working out their
ideas
on different subjects from religious
symbolism to even movies and video games
so make sure you check
all that out on the symbolicworld.com
and if you appreciate what i'm doing
please consider supporting what i'm
doing as well everybody who supports
my my work gets a patron only video once
a month
where i deal on more tricky or prickly
subjects
that are more difficult to to deal with
in these videos that are for
public consumption so check that out and
thank you for your attention